um let me pull up this video because i
recorded some of this last night i was
really worried this would get taken down
or something crazy would happen
guys if you missed this last night we
went on a
ride together we went on a
ride together if you were uh watching
live last night so baked alaska
returned to flagstaff arizona
and went to go get sammy okay so
the excitement starts um
at first when bait goes to get sammy and
flagstaff now it starts off a little
slow
uh they predictably they go to
mcdonald's of course
baked loves his mcdonald's so he gets
her mcdonald's and he picks her up and
uh all i heard last night people kept
telling me was he's going to save her
from her dad or something or she got
kicked out of her house
he's going to save her from her dad and
i'm going this is going to be good so
he goes and gets sammy which is fine it
was pretty boring when he was just
eating in a car with sammy
but when it gets good is
when they go to visit sammy's
dad where's that part at
oh wait a minute was this
oh was that okay so the first part so i
do need my video
okay so i do need my video so i guess
this part of it got taken down
this vod is not uh i guess it's not
around anymore
looks like your boy uh actually came
through here here we go this is better
yo what's up guys thank god
how's it going and we're off to
flagstaff
sorry it's late i'll definitely explain
so come on
by the way d live vods download quality
is not good
explain it
we'll see how it goes you know uh
okay backup actor on rv61
how far are you um
i just left so we'll get to that
real quick by the way i love the irl
stream this is one of the reasons i
barely stream irl
is because his paranoia is showing and i
i totally understand that paranoia like
i get it when you're streaming iron
people where are you at and you go
i'm near at a place
you just don't want to tell these
animals anything
people in here share the stream let's
get it popping boys
happy thanksgiving yoba
what's good okay
cool all right let's flip and go and
then let me get the directions on here
okay cool
so we've got two and a half hours drive
yo yoba
what's good the overseas okay so
what am i doing up in flag um go to see
sammy
so sammy finally yes fine tweet this
yeah tweet the stream link out
let's get this popping 240p for life
can you finish one point if he says
share this link one more time i'm gonna
[ __ ]
i'm going to scream
it's like we heard you we're sharing
get to why you're going there okay baked
i don't have all night
what should be uh should be 1080p
actually
yeah it should be 1080p all right cool
enable stickers uh no i'm gonna try uh
not doing stickers by the way and uh
just having it chat uh
so we'll see we'll see how that works i
think maybe that'll be more fun maybe
it'll
incentivize people to chat more instead
of do stickers
um so we'll see we'll see how it goes
you know we'll see if i don't
know we'll stay tapped in without
stickers you know maybe we can
just stay tapped him with text you know
have a fun chat
do a little trolling like saying
with the monthly sub streak thank you
buddy i appreciate it
um so let me just get on the freeway oh
my god
get to the point less stickers equals
more fun
and the problem is i can't scroll around
too much because this is a really long
video so it's going to skip
way ahead get to the [ __ ] point dude
okay there we go we'll see
i'm thinking we're tapped in yo steal
puma in chat
it's just so this is i'm thinking we're
tapped in yeah we're pretty
pretty flipping tapped in right now um
why are you going to flagstaff to see
sammy stickers are keto hey
we're just gonna no stickers no peace oh
my god
a weekend of content so this this was
probably
not the best time but the chat wanted me
to
and so i didn't i didn't want to let you
guys down i didn't want to let the chat
down
thanks for streaming even though calls
and calls and calls and planning [ __ ]
all day
this is bad man this you know what this
is
this is baked alaska's [ __ ] biggest
weakness
right here he cannot keep a thought
going
like i'll give him credit when he
streams he
[ __ ] plays the n-word on a loop on a
loud speaker in front of
it like there's there's moments he has
moments
i'll give him that he goes around he
maces minorities he gets into like you
know he
is there that stuff's fine but when he
has to just
talk it's he can't do it
he just can't do it and it's i just want
him to explain
like he had to people hey um
this is why i'm doing what i'm doing but
every time like
he is like a cat dude he's literally
like a cat
if if he's trying to he's like yeah
we're going to flagstaff i'm going to
see sammy
uh i got a phone call if you jangle some
keys off to the side
he'll literally go like yeah we're
headed to flagstaff we're gonna
pick up sammy uh i just got a phone call
like it's really bad it's really [ __ ]
bad
you're like you're gonna what you got a
phone you got a what
you got a phone call about what stay
with stay with us here
lucky hex's merch he's trying to get
tapped in
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry that he's trying
to get tapped in is this a new thing now
is this a new word for the gripers this
is tapped in
is that good is that going to be the
word i'm going to hear used to
[ __ ] death and by christmas i'm gonna
want to punch people in the throat that
say it
is that what you're telling me lucky
because i heard that on stream a lot the
other night
so is that what is that my future is my
future now
dreading that when i go to do this show
tampa.ditch.show by the way
on december 12th you come join us tampa
florida still tickets available
after party's been locked and we got a
lot of fun [ __ ] planned for you
december 12th tampa.dick.show get those
tickets well i'm there am i going to
have to now dread over hearing people's
ass tapped in man captain well done
it's kino bro it's tapped in let's go
fire sales is this our lives now
this is what we're doing with our lives
god damn it yo
if not again yeah just say hi to every
single person
hold up was there a message
[Music]
no no message thank you hypnotic hams
love you very much really appreciate
that
um so
yes yes tts is on of course on stream
elements by the way whoever figured out
how to type the mcdonald's logo in
d-live's chat
is a [ __ ] genius you can do that in
the description
um so
[Music]
so yeah we we have we have a super super
packed
weekend of content so this this was
probably not the best time but
the chat wanted me to and so i didn't i
didn't want to let
you guys down i didn't want to let the
chat down thanks for streaming even
though a lot is going on i
yeah you're welcome thank you i for
being appreciative i
appreciate that so i'm not gonna lie i'm
like
i'm like a little like tired a little
out of breath
a little just like stressed um because
like nick's coming into town tomorrow
jaden like a bunch of these
what did i tell you what did i tell you
guys it's a trade show for right-wing
grifters that's all it is
that's all it is it is just an event for
people to get content
post for photo ops and get those super
chats rolling in
that is all it is
it's a trade show it's a convention it's
a glorified
mattress salesman convention for mega
people
that's all it is that's all it is
let me ask you guys an honest question
when it comes to these events
ali alexander uh ashley sinclair
all these other people
what have they done like when you think
of them right like
when you when you think of
when you think of like certain people
you go oh who's that guy oh he's the
host of whatever oh who's that chick oh
she was on bump up up and now she just
pop up
but do you ever notice there's a bunch
of these right-wing personalities
when you when you describe them you go
who is so-and-so and you go oh she's a
right-wing personality
and uh and ashley st claire and all
these other people they're just
the guy in the brick suit that [ __ ]
guy the guy that walks around with
bricks on his suit
some of these people like this was when
we went to deplorapalooza it was driving
me nuts i was
i turned to royce and i go some of these
like what do some of these people do
what do some of these people actually do
and royce was like
i i don't i don't i don't know
i honestly don't know
oh yeah he wears a suit the bricks on it
get it cause of the wall i guess
i guess i get it i don't want it around
but i get it oh dude you know these
dude you got to see you got to meet so
and so oh who's so-and-so
oh they're big on twitter they got their
right wing and they got a big twitter
account
that's it i had to go me
you mean to tell me you're making me
walk away from my friends right now i
got to go over and i got to shake the
hand of somebody
because they got a [ __ ] twitter
account
that's literally what i saw at the
plarapalooza
even at the more alley ah yeah you
should interview view me
what's your name uh i'm i'm uh um
patriot mama on twitter i've got over 25
000 followers on twitter who gives a
[ __ ]
what do you do besides retweet [ __ ]
other people did what do you do
what's your opinion what do you do
that's everybody that's going to be beat
these things now that's why i'm saying i
don't even hate the grifters anymore
anybody who's going that goes uh anybody
that's there to sell a t-shirt
anybody that's there to host a show and
get more network and all that get more
guests fine you can go do that
but but like what what about the ones
that are going that are literally only
going
because they have no personality outside
of mag
i'm worried about these other people
that are strategists
twitter people
even this idiot's gonna be okay guys so
i'm trying to like facilitate that whole
thing
and work with them and then there's an
event saturday
there's gonna be like um people at my
house
people in my house sell t-shirts so i've
been like cleaning
and it's just like i don't know i don't
know if you guys
can relate like me hosting people at my
house and stuff like that is super super
stressful for me i don't know why it's
just like
so many details a million people are
hitting me up like yo can you pick me up
from the airport
and this and that and like dude
obviously
i want to help everyone but i'm just
like
so so overwhelmed like i can't i don't
have
there's only limited things i can do
plus i just took that week off from
streaming
so like it wouldn't be fair to you guys
to like
you know take i don't want to take more
time off i want to keep streaming so
you know it's just i'm just a little
overwhelmed right now
i'm not trying to complain or anything i
just want to let you guys know
just so you kind of know where i'm at uh
know that i'm you know a little
more stressed a little overwhelmed i'm
powering through as much as i can
uh yeah let's get some sami hype slag
celebrating a one month sub streak thank
you buddy
and hey we're going to keep the content
rolling
um and amen i agree with that
we've got an airbnb happening
that's going to be dope avoid getting
arrested tonight
please uh yeah all right so let's skip
this this is boring so he drove all
[Music]
this time okay
wait is this where did it cut off before
they went to the okay so i do have that
other video
wow they took down a lot of this this is
the [ __ ] i saved
but uh let's get to where it gets with
the queen sammy
sammy's back sammy's back
do you often do you often carry lighters
with your passengers
[Music]
yeah sure no i normally don't uh someone
brought this in the car because they
were smoking a cigarette
oh how dare them i know him
it's been so long no it hasn't yeah it
was like
it's been like a month it has all right
stop talking that long it's really
[ __ ] beta
[Music]
my dad's being mean to me he's trying to
destroy your phone
uh yeah he broke my other phone tell me
why he did that
it's not very nice i'm sure he has the
motive
you want to go to mcdonald's mcdonald's
yeah
donald's andy my treat hey sammy why do
you lark with the childish voice
instagram you clearly had a much deeper
voice
by the way this chat
i mean right away people wasted
absolutely no time piling onto sammy
what's the deal
speak with your real voice already
because i was provoked and everybody had
sammy is the best happy thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving
yes he's obsessed with mcdonald's dick
rich he says yeah and i'll be honest
like i
since i moved i've been eating more
mcdonald's because there's one right by
here and it's just
easy but even i don't eat as much
mcdonald's as this guy does like it
i don't know how you can eat it that i
love mcdonald's i genuinely do
i'm not one of these people that's like
it's [ __ ] poison man you book it i
know it's bad for you and i know it's
not good food but
it's it is good and you know people who
grew up eating mcdonald's mcdonald's
[ __ ] big mac and a coke especially if
it's not shitty and it's been sitting
under a heat lamp
but when you go to a nice mcdonald's
it's like in a white neighborhood and
you get
like a [ __ ] big mac and some fries or
some nuggets
that [ __ ] is delicious objectively but
if i eat it more than like twice a week
or something
it's just like eventually like all right
i don't you know what i mean like i
don't
i don't want it this dude eats it like
three times a day bro like he lives on
mcdonald's
happy thanksgiving if ever okay robot
you're just jealous because you only
have one tone of voice
you have different voices
what was that human nature whoa
i didn't see this what was that
that was wild did you see that
did you guys see like the [ __ ]
remember the hillary clinton um
do you remember when hillary clinton
did the wow thing
that's what that just reminded me of
she's fat now
i'm bad with your real voice already
i want to see this again
and everybody has sammy is the best
happy thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving yes you're right
if ever okay robot you're just jealous
because you only have one tone of voice
you have different voices
uh
[Music]
that you have according to the situation
you're in and
i don't know if you think you're better
than me robot but if you were in my
situation you probably would have a
deeper voice too
she still talks to it like it's a robot
like she replies
to the robot she thinks a robot
is just she thinks that baked alaska has
a robot sidekick that hates her guts
basically
which is kind of funny you missed the
robot didn't you a little bit
you you and the robot have had you know
gone through your ups and downs
you had a good time
she's like no um i'm over the robot
so what's good so what's going on with
your dad like i feel like
you need to like get out this doesn't
seem like a healthy situation
inside violence intentionally and that's
why you put cranberry sauce over the
counter
obviously there's and he was on the
ceiling
yeah no he put a one saucer feeling
yeah i saw your video on instagram i'm
glad you're exposing it
yeah so she's talking about her dad and
how crazy he is and how he's abusing her
and how she's doing all this [ __ ] he
broke her phone and he's spraying a1
sauce all over the ceilings
so of course what would be the best
course action
let's go hang out at sammy's house with
her dad
[Laughter]
oh boy get ready for a wild ride we're
just getting warmed up tonight guys
nobody's really gonna see it
they're trying to i don't know what
they're trying to do sammy i want you
i want you to know something i have
never had longer armpits your dad
[ __ ] his pants is not funny you're
right
it's not funny it's not funny at all
never laugh or something like that
okay i got i hate this
i i hate that i even have to admit this
but baked made me laugh last night
and it's very rare it's very rare
i i i think it might be the first time
baked allez has ever actually made me
laugh but she brought up her dad
shooting her pants and saying it's not
funny and he
to his to his [ __ ] to his credit he
deadpan looked her in her face straight
faced and went
i would never ever laugh about your dad
[ __ ] his pants
and he just [ __ ] and he just kept
this is really
this did actually make me laugh i gotta
go back a little bit
yeah what do you think this is it's just
a way that people make things
look like things that they aren't okay
co-video
manipulation through photography
videography
i agree with that yeah and photoshop and
all the other
[ __ ] they're trying to i don't know
what they're trying to do sammy
i want you i want you to know something
i have never had longer
armpits your dad [ __ ] his pants is
not funny you're right
it's not funny it's not funny at all but
i always i would never laugh at
something like that
i would never laugh at your dad's
[ __ ] his pants
soiling himself and bending over in the
middle of the street and rubbing it all
over
i would never laugh at that what about
what happened to my eye
in phoenix do you even know what
happened to you
by the way he he has to be a legit
sociopath because i couldn't
there's no way i can usually hold in a
laugh
but how do you hold that i don't know
how he held in that letter but jesus
christ
i was i was i that was the first time in
my life i could remember baked alaska
making me laugh on purpose i was
i was howling in howling clove hair
[Music]
i would never there is something
abrasive that's your dad
just say this [ __ ] the best way to
put this
rubbing it all over him i would never
laugh at that did your dad ever spank
you
if he didn't he probably should have
baked
it's time to step up and do what her dad
never did
there was something abrasive that
happened
no it's not funny but you know what i
have i have a way
of because i've been through so so much
in my life i have a way of getting over
things quickly
and so i try to not let them affect me i
try to just move on and focus on the
positive
being positive and productive and going
on with my life because it's good
because focusing on the bad thing that
people gotta get
is not good you gotta be positive and
productive that's right is not gonna
change anything it's not gonna change
the future so
but people don't realize how much i've
really been through
because because you've been through a
lot because i continue to vote for an
oscar already you've been through
she is an incredible actress has nothing
on you sammy
so i could really talk and not have to
worry about you
please talk let your voice be heard
sammy
so what what i'm trying to say is a lot
of people don't realize
the extent of what i'm really going
through because i try to
carry myself as best i can and try to
bounce back and some days are better
than others
sometimes people all right this is
getting boring i got to get you guys to
the good stuff here
what is this not a fed kept donating
last night amanda taylor
some handed it by the way i did not know
that was you not a fed
that was making me laugh so much like
dude i would have this on last night and
i had my speakers on not my headphones
so i was watching this but i was also
like not watching it like i was
just doing other things in the studio
and every time i'd be like getting out
of these like organizing the closet and
stuff i would hear your donors of amanda
taylor
amanda taylor amanda i'd just be dying
laughing
and i was like i was the first one to do
the repeating amanda taylor donos
and interrupting me when i had something
i was dying when i heard yourself it's a
test i'm trying to
by the way shout out to adonis paul from
adonis paul's pleasure palace
don't worry everyone's life is hell it's
not just yours and it only gets worse
from here
it's worse from here make out with baked
you will feel better
persecute the real criminals and stop
trying to falsify evidence and make
things look like things that they're not
and trying to go talk to dad alone for a
minute
man to man mono y mono then you three
can party and have positive vibes all
night
no he liked me oh wait no this so this
was the second trip back so i almost
ruined it here
oh man i'm glad i realized this because
this was when they went back to the
house let's
let's let's check out the first
encounter they had with dear old dad
because the first the first encounter
they had with dad
was uh boy was it something else
this is when they went there earlier
[Music]
get out of my life get out of my life
just leave just go with him okay
okay do you have dude do you have any
stuff does she have any stuff here who's
making you treat me like this
you shouldn't want to know yeah is there
any of her stuff here she needs to know
i want to know who is making you by the
way correct d-ball money that is not a
house that's inefficiency
treat me like this tell him who
who's doing this to you and me
i'm not gonna acknowledge you because
you're [ __ ] nuts
you're [ __ ] nuts
holy [ __ ] i love you and i know you're a
good man and i know you want to be great
around my life he's a good man okay
didn't you invite her to stay here with
you jesus christ
you're my favorite person in the whole
world and that's probably why you're
being so mean to me because i care about
you the most
anyway jesus is
[Music]
say crazy you gotta say he literally
said you're a freak
get away from me
dude by the way somebody said last night
on twitter this is like a rob zombie
movie and i was like it really is
holy [ __ ] dude i would have been [ __ ]
out of there man
content or no content i would have been
like oh you got to get the [ __ ] out of
here
this is going to be bad listen i love
[ __ ] freak yeah
[Laughter]
[ __ ] man because it's a bat
he's not doing this on his own i know
anyway look okay so see these remotes
you see these he'll sleep with these
like this
and he'll put like uh screwdrivers and
he'll sleep with his tweezers
do you know i just called the police i
said the next time you walk in the door
you're going to be arrested so do not do
this you're falsifying evidence
no you're not supposed to be on my
property
so who do i need to contact the mayor
and ask him who he's been sleeping with
or something because
this isn't what a [ __ ] justifiable
holy [ __ ] no you've got a mad man
already slept with her
and you already know who's doing get the
[ __ ] out of my house oh i was
screenshotting
my house okay so anyway i was
screenshotting this for twitter
what is this what is this green beans
yeah what is that you guys have a good
thanksgiving ew is that thanksgiving to
you
i already threw out all the cranberry
sauce oh and what are these
these are like beers that we're getting
do you know if there's any bars open
we're trying to maybe
go to a bar or something are there any
bars open around here
um uh maybe
maybe near uh downtown and i sleep in
that counter
oh i want to show you something i want
to say something dad you get that
look at this this is weird by the way i
don't know if you notice that that'll um
that's gonna come into play again later
she sleeps in that corner
is literally what she just said
but oh you have to bend down to see it
but what is that
in that corner by the way
that oven is on that oven is
yes long the that oven is had
she they walked in and the dad's just
hanging out whatever there's nothing in
the oven
and she goes check this out she over the
oven is you can tell it's been on
because it's red hot so he's just
hanging out with the oven
this whole thing is just a mess that's
central heat people are saying poverty
eater
it could be i didn't think of it that
way but yeah
yeah what is that thing right there do
you see that um
it's just an oven is that a heating
element what is that
it's just a norm this isn't normal it's
just normal
[Music]
yeah okay well
yeah i mean i remember you thought like
different things on your rv
were like spying devices or something
i'm not stupid
i'm not saying you're super yeah but
you're just very i am you're very
curious
a single
just take your [ __ ] and get out of the
house
this [ __ ] guy
you don't understand i couldn't handle
this last night
does this guy have any weed i
i was i there was so many layers of
madness
i was just [ __ ] this dad
is the coolest dude sammy and her dad
are a
show right there [ __ ] rv seven [ __ ]
streamer houses
[ __ ] all the jake logan pulse of the
world
we just need sammy and her dad we set up
a couple of those blink cameras and the
[ __ ] efficiency
hook it all up through the router bam
streamer efficiency
this does this guy have any week
scuffed
we could like go to a liquor store or
something um no no no no
you want to come with us to the bar no
we could bring we could bring some
liquor here
you wanted me to bring some drinks back
you can and you're welcome to come back
with him
and hang out because i'm gonna be laying
down okay
okay i'm gonna be laying down and please
keep your remote
now shut up just listen you're welcome
to come back in about
hours so we want to see i love it and
and just hang on
if you want okay thanks cool i
appreciate that yeah sure
yeah it's already in school so go go
just go okay okay get out of
have a good one